we're all here because we have concerns
about the sea
see you bought defense contractor stock
before railing against profitable wars
your words and actions are consistently
inconsistent no bill you've authored has
passed and you have no committee power
to advocate for this district
without resorting to rhetoric about
democrat boogeyman biden and the wolf
left answer this can you tell us one or
two specific objectives that affect our
wallets that you can actually pass and
explain how you plan to get it done
without being guaranteed a committee
assignment well thank you for that
question seth and i know you this is
your first time being a candidate as
well
so i usually find out about stock trades
when i read them in the news just like
you have i signed an agreement with our
financial advisor that i don't know
anything about trades that are made on
behalf of me or my husband when they're
made i always find out about them when
they're written by leftist like business
insider just like you're talking about
now here's what we have to do you have
to understand and remember democrats are
in control in washington right now
republicans aren't getting anything done
even the republicans on committees
aren't getting anything done and if they
were you wouldn't see the radical
destruction of america going on right
now are wide open borders we are having
inflation out of control and we are no
longer energy independent as americans
so what i look forward to doing is when
we take back the house i'll have great
committee assignments kevin mccarthy and
leadership have already promised to them
them to me and we look forward to
holding democrats accountable for all
the corruption and horrible things
they've done in our country thank you
okay let's give us seth uh 30 seconds to
respond
that's too big an if
uh voting for mrs green is a gamble that
she's not guaranteed a committee power
she's not even accountable for her own
tweets or her staffs
we're still not clear who's acting on
the district's behalf so how can anyone
expect her to bring accountability to
washington
her only leadership trait right now is
rallying people against an enemy
and little to none of what she just said
encourages business in our district
or fights out of control inflation
speaking of white nationalists marjorie
taylor greene she was at it at her
republican primary debate do you think
she says the words do not recall i'm
almost
i i almost think that's like a like a
recording that she has that she's like i
do not recall i do know she has an easy
button right right right
she likes your mouth any move it's just
just like just pull the string on the
dummy
well i mean you know
you're what you're going to see here is
a bunch of lawyer talk this person is is
obviously
and her attorneys obviously think that
she actually has some criminal liability
towards the insurrection to some degree
otherwise she wouldn't say some of the
stuff she's saying how she's saying it
safe to assume she does not say i don't
recall i think she's gonna answer but i
wouldn't be surprised if she also gives
a non-answer well i mean this is
marjorie taylor green right she's gonna
i mean here's the thing he said don't
mention like the woke left in this i i
have a feeling throw it in there
she's she may not say woke left exactly
but i i bet she throws something in
there that's like something to the of
the deep state or whatever the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that she tries to smear all
over there i guarantee she gives a
non-answer and tries to blame someone
else you haven't seen this clip then you
haven't watched no no no well thank you
for that question seth and and i know
you this is your first time being a
candidate as well
so i usually find out about stock trades
when i read them in the news just like
you have i signed an agreement with our
financial advisor that i don't know
anything about trades that are made on
that she doesn't recall gabe she doesn't
recall
she didn't say i don't recall
this is a [ __ ] answer i always find
out about them when they're written by
leftist like business insider there it
is there it is there's leftist like
business business insider you bunch of
[ __ ] lessons so that means wait hold
on so that means she gets if you recall
what she just said she said she does not
hear about them until they're in the
right in the trades right
and then she she signed an agreement
which doesn't really mean anything in
terms of with her financial advisor now
what she's saying is she doesn't hear
about them until they're in leftist uh
articles like business insider which
means she's getting her trade
information from leftist articles right
in publications right this answer is
[ __ ] just like you're talking about
now here's what we have to do you have
to understand and remember democrats are
in control in washington right now she's
telling other people to remember right
right the person who doesn't recall
anything is telling other people to
remember all right so she didn't say
deep state she didn't say woke left she
said the democrats are in control so she
it sounds like she's going to blame them
right well we're not getting anything
done right absolutely republicans aren't
getting anything done even the
republicans on committees aren't getting
anything done and it's so so now so now
it's anyone who's not on a committee are
the actual ones who are getting things
done right do you notice that democrats
who are on committees are in control of
committees they're not getting anything
the republicans who are actually on
committee escape they're not getting
anything done
they're definitely it's the only the
only people like me who are not on
committees right
who can't introduce legislation into
committees to make sure they get to the
house floor i can only go to the house
floor and [ __ ] and [ __ ] and [ __ ] in
front of a microphone and be a racist
white nationalist piece of [ __ ]
a manga king uh mass shooter enabler and
then that that's the only that's the
only voice that i have what a bonehead
what did i say a non-answer she went in
he was like yo give me the actual
policies that you will pass if you are
re-elected and she goes in and says well
you know it's run by the democrats the
house and the the hill and uh we don't
really have as much uh control as we did
once but once i'm reelected uh kevin
mccarthy told me he's promised me so
just go to take me take my word for it
that word [ __ ] two cents that when i
get back into that seat for this
district
kevin mccarthy is going to put me on a
that's right on a on a committee he's
going to put me on many committees he's
going to be on so many committees he's
going to be the best committees ever
right
like that's the type of [ __ ] she's
trying to say right now i did not hear
one
actual thing that could be done which is
a non-rep she doesn't do anything and
was not able to provide any sort of
answer that says oh yeah yeah when i'm
re-elected if i'm re-elected i will do
these things the insane q anon
right-wing pro-fascist type of
legislation you try to pass this little
clip of marjorie taylor greene saying
that kevin mccarthy is going to promise
her her committees back is all you need
democrats out there when we get to the
general to make commercials that their
party leader marjorie taylor green
is going to get her
committees back and she's going to use
her gavel as she can
to
turn this into a fascist state